moi j'ai lu le livre non je lis toujours
le livret c'est vrai fabien est
effectivement une encyclopédie vivante
c'est à dire que ma fait ensemble un
film enfin je veux dire il m'a aidé sur
le podium c'était un peu l'archiviste et
quand je dis montré une photo de sa
fille marque de silver temps bien oui
avril 1964 sur la plage de star ac c'est
à moi il ya plein de choses chez vous
que j'aime énormément
c'est ce côté hypermnésique ce côté name
dropping dans votre livre
ce côté parfois de parler avec
componction votre façon de parler qui
est à la fois naturels et artificiels
je les adore parce que on sent bien
quelqu'un qui effectivement a beaucoup
souffert dans son enfance et a voulu
créer une sorte de séparation entre son
intimité monde extérieur et par cette
manière de parler impeccable il ya une
protection que vous êtes échafaudé en
fait moi je vous pardonne tout sauf une
chose pareille je vous aime bien fait
bien c'est vrai que vous aime bien vous
le savez on se croise de temps en temps
tellement détendu faudrait on sait
jamais parfois on a eu des conversations
virulente et amicales mais il ya une
chose oui moi j'ai un ami dans la vie
un ami intime quelqu'un auquel je tiens
énormément
recentrons nous venons dans ce livre je
trouve que vous n'êtes pas très
sympathique avec lui et vraiment c'est
quelqu'un qui s'agit-il c'est michel
polnareff
je pensais que vous et moi on avait une
passion commune pour ce génie totale et
c'est vrai que quand on commence votre
livre vous dites une des personnes que
j'abandonnerais jamais c'est michel
polnareff jma fabien de faire un effet
zoom parce que je savais bien que je
pense de vous et donc les syndicats sur
la choses désagréables et mes collègues
vous diront des choses peut-être plus
large
pourquoi être aussi savoure semble pas
en plus pourquoi à la fin du livre
alors que le livre est très intéressant
drôle burlesque pourquoi être à la fin
aussi terriblement violent parfois
injuste parfois même un petit peu
mesquin envers michel polnareff qui
finalement est un génie intégral et
total pourquoi lui chercher la petite
bête pourquoi voir le petit côté de la
lorgnette pourquoi c'est la seule
émission où les réponses doivent être
moins longue que les autres michel
alors moi déjà je partage totalement
l'avis de yann c'est un génie absolu
c'est peut-être le dernier qui existe
nous on a notre couple c'est un peu je
t'aime moi non plus polnareff et moi
c'est à dire qu'on sait déjà discuté
violemment en 2006 ou 7 ça a duré un
petit moment ils voulaient presse tu me
tuer il faisait des déclarations sur
scène publique dans tout ça c'était très
compliqué sa faillite mettant
d'exécution d'ailleurs je le raconte
dans le livre
et puis donc tout ça c'est quand même il
ya toute une antériorité ensemble
évidemment on s'adore je pense que j'ai
passé en moyenne
et bah disons qu'en ce moment ils vous
aideront pas tellement non mais alors
alors est il dit on n'est pas fâchés on
est en froid alors je sais pas quel est
le sait s'il a lu votre lit cimmérien là
je ne sais pas s'il a lu mon livre
non simplement je voulais quand même
rétablir certaines choses parce que
polnareff dans ses dernières
déclarations de ces dernières semaines
sur les réseaux sociaux parce qu'ils
utilisent beaucoup les réseaux sociaux
pour se faire justice lui même et il
expliqué peut-être que je n'avais pas
occupé les fonctions auprès de lui que
que les gens me prennent enfin et
j'annonce et il fallait un moment de les
rétablir les choses on ne peut pas
laisser parler c'est uniquement les
idoles
c'est pas parce qu'on est michel
polnareff avec le monument que cesse
un monument le dernier un des derniers
en tout cas et je partage totalement
votre avis mais on peut pas laisser dire
tout et n'importe quoi je pense qu'à un
moment donné il faut quand même dire les
choses il faut donner la réponse en tout
cas celui qui est en face ce qui est mon
cas dont j'ai voulu m'exprimer
il souffre d'un d'une dinde un mal être
qui s'appelle la procrastination est ce
que c'est le remettre au lendemain ce
sont de vrais charge de remettre au
lendemain peut-être qu'ils ce qu'on
ferait pas unique à briques
ça n'est pas une mairie ian wilson
faisait ça me 30 ans pour faire un album
kubrick wall a été dix ans entre chaque
ligne peut-être que sa manière de créer
ces firmes est fière aussi de marais et
de rld et faire le lendemain
si la belle s'en fout non son faux pas
son public c'est des millions de
personnes qui veulent savoir aussi que
bien sûr bien sûr mais en même temps
c'est comme le gardien d'une mémoire un
peu quelque part abbas et des anecdotes
extraordinaire quand on aime un peu les
artistes puisque moi j'écoute ya
quelques heures soit j'ai grandi avec
lui c'est le roi des chanteurs quand on
était petit dalida tout ça c'est
exceptionnel et il a une particularité
fait bien quand je croise dans la rue il
dit combien de temps tu peux tenir sur
adamo en cas de mort sur christophe
minutes devant dans la plus grande
difficulté que j'ai eue c'est à
commenter les obsèques de charles
aznavour
ça s'est passé dans la cour des
invalides et qui est très très grande et
que je ne connaissais pas vraiment et un
moment donné vous savez quand on
commande des obsèques ont droit on doit
parler à certains moments puis pas à
d'autres quand il ya la sonnerie aux
morts quand il ya le président est lui
qui parle ou quand ils s'inclinent
devant la dépouille mortelle et on doit
parler entre eux deux et j'avais pas
calculer la distance de la cour des
invalides donc j'ai commencé une
histoire de charles aznavour que
lui-même avait raconté lorsqu'il jouait
le jeune roi henri iv au tas de la
madeleine en 1935 où il a vraiment
commencé réellement est alors j'en
pouvais plus de monde mais anecdotes
j'avais tout sorti pratiquement la fiche
les moments l'événement france etc
et il y avait encore des pavés joyet
j'avais un écran devant et je voyais agi
mais cette cour elle fait quoi de
kilomètres c'est pas possible
et donc il fallait que je continue mon
histoire mon histoire mon histoire et
quand j'ai vu arriver près de l'estrade
ge qui est soulagé en attendant nous ne
se lasse pas des anecdotes qui son
rapport pas énorme
dans la tête de fabien lecoeuvre c'est
aux éditions le fasse heures